hey what's happening my name's samuel
leeds and if you are new to property
investment i'm going to be sharing in
this video some things that you can do
literally over the next few days to
start seeing results in your property
investment journey now this could result
in you finding your first property
investment deal that you can buy
yourself
or a property that you can find that you
can also package it and sell it to make
money from an investor or option number
three is by finding a property that you
can then joint venture with so those are
the three options so what i want you to
do because this is not going to be a
usual youtube video where you can watch
it passively or skip it i want you to
watch this video from start to finish
because i'm going to be revealing some
real strong golden nuggets i have zero
intention of making this youtube video
apart from wanting to see you succeed
right now i'm in dubai with my beautiful
wife and we're about to go out for a
lovely dinner but listen i've made a lot
of money in property investment
over the last 13 years i'm 30 years old
i've made millions of pounds and i
started with absolutely nothing so i
really enjoy giving back and sharing
tips and strategies to help other people
in the same way that i got helped i got
supported by people because believe it
or not in property it's a really
interesting culture it's a really
interesting corporation and profession
because usually speaking property
investors want other property investors
to be successful isn't that amazing you
never usually see that in most
industries normally everyone's trying to
hold each other down and i think the
reason that property investors want
other property investors to win is
because they collaborate with each other
so often and who knows maybe you and me
will do a property joint venture one day
real soon so first thing i want to do is
i want you to commit to watching this
video till the very end because i'm
gonna be sharing stuff i've not shared
ever before publicly on youtube but this
is a special christmas gift while i'm
out on holiday in dubai
and the second thing is please do me a
massive favor and if you want other
people in the same way that i want you
to win
if you want other people to win and
benefit from this which you should
because by them winning you're not
losing anything um please do hit the
like button because if you like the
video it will push it up on the youtube
algorithm so more people will have the
opportunity to see the video so first
things first i hope you've liked the
video um what i want to do is i want you
to decide
which one of the three types of deals
would you like to do so number one maybe
you've got money
and you just want to invest that money
into a property investment yourself
that's option a
option b is maybe you have got no money
and you could really do with making a
few extra thousand pounds
this year to pay for your expensive
christmas that you've just had and uh if
you'd like to just make a few thousand
pounds as a one-off then that's option
number two option b
and option c is if you've not got much
money but you really want to get your
foot on the door in property and you
want to become a property owner you want
to become a first-time property investor
but you haven't quite got enough money
to stretch up to get yourself on the
ladder or so you thought you didn't but
maybe on this video you realize that you
actually have that's option c so i want
you to make a decision right now and i
want you to
write down or even you can comment in
the youtube box if you want let me know
what type of because as you speak out
and as you write it you manifest it
because clarity brings power so why
don't you uh let me know in the comments
or you can write down and keep it
private are you option a b or c
next
if you are option b or c and you have no
money or a little bit of money
you need
other property investors
to come and back your deals to help
finance your deals
believe me if you can find the right
types of deals
there will be investors that will back
your deals how do i know that because i
myself often fund and back other
people's deals so if you're b or c uh if
you're a and you just want to buy a
property itself just bear with me just
real real briefly but if you're b or c
then you need to start speaking to other
property investors and asking them what
they're looking for so i'll tell you
right now what i'm looking for
i'm looking for development
opportunities in the buckinghamshire
area or i'm looking for large houses in
london that can be turned into
residential flats that's what i'm
looking for i'm an investor
so your job now is to find other
investors and to find out what it is
that they are looking for so you can go
to
facebook groups i run a facebook group
myself which has got over 30 000 can you
believe it 30 000 uh property investors
are part of the facebook group uh it's
called property investors with samuel
leeds i'll leave a link in the
description so you can join the facebook
group for free
and post on the group and say
what's everyone looking to buy at the
moment what types of property deals are
you looking for
and then they'll tell you
what types of property investments
they're looking for so if you're option
b or c and you haven't got much money
you need to find other investors and
find out what they are looking for
now once you've done that the date right
now is the 27th
i believe this is the time of the year
most people don't even know what day it
is now on the 29th
that means the day after tomorrow
estate agents open again now maybe
you're watching this in the new year
which is great because estate agents are
already open but if you're watching this
the day i've posted it estate agents are
about to open now after christmas and in
the new year it's a fabulous time to
find good property investments why
because everybody that was trying to
sell their house in november and
december if the house didn't sell then
they become really motivated because uh
my arm's getting a bit tired so i'm just
gonna sit down for a moment and pop this
down um because they're really motivated
because if they've not sold their house
and it's now after christmas
then they're thinking oh my goodness
is this house ever gonna sell so after
christmas and in the new year is a
really good opportunity to buy cheap
below market value deals
so
if you're person a i want you to think
what kind of a property do you want to
buy are you looking for
houses of multiple occupancy houses that
you can buy and rent out on a room by
room basis are you looking for buy to
let properties properties with just a
good yield so
write down or you can hit it in the
comments what type of property you're
looking for or what kind of a property
your fellow investors are looking for
then what are you going to do
you're going to hit the phone you're
going to phone up your estate agents
that have just finished christmas and
have still got these angry sellers that
are ringing them up every day saying
my house still hasn't sold
why isn't my house sold you promised it
would be sold by christmas you're going
to ring up these estate agents how are
you going to find these estate agents
well
if you go to rightmove
rightmove.co.uk
you can look for houses and you can
search for houses
on youtube on the search bar from oldest
listed so you're going to look for all
the houses that have been on the market
in your area for a few months now that
haven't sold
they're going to be so disappointed to
see that their house is now getting
pushed back onto another year 2022.
ring up those estate agents
and ask them the question
just ask the question and say hey
i noticed that
whatever the property is number 32
church road i've just seen it on
rightmove i noticed that it's been
around a few months and it's still not
sold
listen i am an investor
and i am looking for a um a discounted
price so i can see that the property's
on the market for 150 000 pounds let's
say so you know realistically i'd only
be able to offer a roundabout and then
offer over the phone before you've seen
it about eighty percent of the market
value so if it's on for 150 000 pounds
you can say listen i'd only
realistically be able to offer around
about 120
000 pounds
um
is it worth booking a viewing on this
property or not now the estate agent
might say oh no chance they're really
stubborn but if the estate agent is
having that seller
breathing down their neck really
motivated to sell then the estate agent
is very likely to say you know what
that is a bit of a cheeky offer but
the seller is motivated come and have a
look
you just bagged yourself a property 20
below market value and then of course
you have to view the property and
check that the property's in good
condition and do your due diligence
but that's how you can make the most in
2022 of finding the best juiciest deals
now if you're looking to buy yourself
and you've got a little bit of a little
pot of money and you're looking to
invest this is the way to do it never
buy a house at full asking price never
just go and buy a house that you like
based on your feelings and rent it out
always buy on formulas and always buy at
a discount and if you're planning on
packaging a property to sell it to an
investor then if an estate agent says
yes we'd be open to selling it at a
discount
then you can contact that investor that
said they were looking for that
particular type property in that
particular area and say hey
i found a property
just like the type of property you were
looking for and i've managed to
negotiate 30 000 pounds off of the price
would you like me to introduce you
all i want is a 3 000 pounds
finders fee
i mean
of course it's a no-brainer for them
because if they're looking to buy a
property anyway in this market and
you've just negotiated 30 grand discount
of course they'd happily take a 27 grand
discount and give you 3 000 pounds but
from your perspective you just made
three thousand pounds for making a few
phone calls and doing a cheeky facebook
post
now if you're wanting to get on the
property ladder as a joint venture i
would recommend that you only join
venture with somebody that you know and
you like and you trust but it's the same
concept so you're going to negotiate to
buy a discount you're going to find a
juicy investment and you're going to ask
them
to put the money in
but for you
to put all the time and effort and
manage the property and find it and
source it and negotiate it a cheap price
for a percentage of the future profits
this is how you can become a property
owner or a part to property owner i
should say with your sweat equity
because elbow grease as opposed to
having to actually save up money for a
deposit you're going to put your time
and energy into finding the best deals
on the market and in return you're going
to get a percentage of the profits on
that house which is an incredible way of
getting your foot
through the door in the property market
starting with little money so estate
agents are opening
20 20 uh 2022 it's almost oh i forgot
how to say that 2022 is amongst us so
why don't you start
speaking to agents
searching on rightmove
networking and trying to find those
juicy deals because they do exist
believe me that's how i got started 13
years ago and when you buy the right
properties not only do you get paid rent
from them but they also go up in value
and most people become wealthy not by
going to school not by going to
university but most people that create
true wealth do so in property investment
and that's certainly been the case for
me i started with nothing and
i'm really humbled
and in a very fortunate situation that
now myself my family my three children
my wife we're financially secure and
that's that all thanks to property and
all thanks to the people that believed
in me and gave me these types of tips
which i'm now sharing on youtube so if
you're not already a subscriber
subscribe to the channel have a very
happy new year and i will see you guys
next time